la ce a lieu dans un quartier pourri ils
ont filmé les grands ensembles samedi à
15h15 sur public sénat
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat à suivre ce matin sur
notre antenne à les travaux de la
commission d' enquête sur l'évasion
fiscale les sénateurs auditionnent jean
pierre jouyet président de la ffc
l'autorité des marchés financiers
l'objectif de cette commission d'enquêté
d'évaluer plus précisément l'ampleur de
ce phénomène
selon éric bocquet le rapporteur de
cette commission denquête l'état
français perdre est en effet entre 50 et
80 milliards d'euros de recettes à cause
de l'évasion fiscale tout de suite donc
sans plus tarder direction la salle
clémenceau bonne matinée à tous je vous
rappelle messieurs que conformément aux
termes de l'article 6 de l'ordonance du
17 à 25 ans cuite relatives au
fonctionnement des assemblées
parlementaires votre audition doit se
tenir sous serment et que tout faux
témoignages faits passibles des peines
prévues aux articles 4 134 tirs et 13
400 34-15 du code pénal en conséquence
je vais vous demander de prêter serment
de dire toute la vérité rien que la
vérité pour ce faire vous lèverez la
main droite c'est vous dire et je ne
cherche vous invite à le faire je le
jure si je le jure merci donc je vous
propose de commencer cette édition par
un exposé liminaire puis de répondre aux
questions de notre rapporteur monsieur
éric bocquet et puis après procéderont
aux questions réponses des membres de la
commission pour approfondir le débat
chez président vous avez la parole
très bien merci beaucoup monsieur le
président monsieur le rapport sur le
rapporteur madame la vice présidente
mesdames et messieurs les parlementaires
je vous remercie de nous avoir convié
avec le secrétaire général thierry
francq se fit quatre hommes que vous
connaissez bien nous exprimer sur ce
sujet important et j'allais dire est
récurrent de l'évasion des capitaux même
si c'est un sujet sur lesquels avec le
secrétaire général nous avons davantage
travailler dans des fonctions
antérieures que dans celle ci
et tiens vous préciser qu'au regard de
ses missions le rôle de la mf dans la
lutte contre l'évasion fiscale n'est pas
direct mais nous le comtois ions par le
biais des enquêtes et de la lutte contre
le blanchiment
au plan international l'autorité des
marchés financiers coopère avec ses
homologues dans le strict cadre de ses
compétences à l'exclusion de toute
question fiscale qui reste hors champ
des compétences de l'autorité des
marchés financiers y compris dans les
relations avec ses homologues alors
furent le champ de compétence de la mf
il est limité à la matière boursière et
financière ne peut donc pas recherché
dans le cadre de ces enquêtes de ce
contrôle de possibles de délits fiscaux
cependant comme vous le savez au vu de
ce une disposition du code pénal
au vu de ce que de ce qu'est le code
monétaire et financier
si dans le cadre de ses attributions
l'autorité des marchés financiers
acquiert la connaissance d'un crime ou
d'un délit est tenu d'en informer en
donner avis sans délai au procureur de
la république à qui elle doit
transmettre tous les renseignements
procès verbaux et actes qui y sont
relatifs ainsi ces dernières années 2
enquête relevait de la fraude fiscale et
ont été transmises au parquet et à
tracfin
la première enquête concerne est une
entité dont le siège social théorique
était au luxembourg mais le siège
effectifs étaient en france ce qui a
constitué une fraude à l'impôt sur les
sociétés suivies d'une fraude ali sf du
dirigeant sur l'autre enquête il
s'agissait d' opérations capitalistiques
très complexe avec dissimulation d'un
produit 200 millions d'euros le
secrétaire généra souhaitera peut-être
s'exprimer sur ces enquêtes puisque
c'est lui qui les conduit dans le cadre
de la répartition des pouvoirs
l'autorité des marchés financiers dans
ce cadre nous ne transmettons pas office
que nos résultats car cela est contraire
à nos accords de coopération
internationale on les transmet au
parquet et à tracfin me direz pourquoi
sous le contrôle du secrétaire général
c'est parce que dans la coopération
administrative que nous avons comme pour
d'autres autorités
la coopération administrative et limiter
au champ de spécialisation des autorités
administratives donc quand nous
coopérons avec la haye si si quand nous
coopérons l'autorité américaine comme un
coupé rompt avec le fsr autorités
britanniques avec la bafin l'autorité
allemande et les autorités
luxembourgeoises ou avec encore d'autres
autorités
nous coopérons sur les informations
recueillies aux fins de ce que sont nos
compétences et dans les accords que nous
avons et dans le ce qu'elle cadre de
l'organisation internationale des
marchés financiers et aux ce qu il est
très clairement indiqué qu on ne doit
pas outrepasser les mandats qui sont les
nôtres dans le cadre de la coopération
les gens aimant bien savoir déjà pour
vous dire la vérité puisque la vie
lorsque vous transmettez parce qu'ils
savent que l'on transmet des
informations à la justice
deux fois quand même à le regarder parce
que même pour la transmission à la
justice en les accords de coopération
internationale administrative vous
pouvez avoir un certain nombre de
limitations
alors malgré tout à plusieurs reprises
les autorités françaises ont réitéré
leur volonté de s'inscrire en première
ligne de la lutte contre le blanchiment
des capitaux ce positionnement est un
enjeu pour le régulateur c'est bien
évidemment un enjeu réputationnel
économique nous si politique puisque ce
thème était à l'ordre du jour de la
présidence française du g20 à cette
occasion la france a voulu relier plus
lisiblement les trois thèmes du
blanchiment de l'opacité fiscales et des
cadres réglementaires en visant
explicitement les paradis fiscaux est
encore élan étroitement cette lutte
à la question de l'aide au développement
alors dès le début du mandat que nous
avons exercé avec le secrétaire général
nous avons souhaité que la lutte contre
le blanchiment des think tanks des
capitaux s'inscrivent dans le plan
stratégique de l'autorité des marchés
financiers et jeu que nous puissions
nous a serré en ce domaine
comme vous le savez le gafi a élaboré
des standards de référence que les pays
doivent mettre en place il s'agit de 40
recommandations sur la lutte contre le
blanchiment des capitaux et neuf sur le
financement du terrorisme
c'est dans ce cadre que se déroulait en
mai 2009
l'évaluation de la conformité du
dispositif français de lutte anti
blanchiment et de lutte contre le
terrorisme à laquelle l'autorité des
marchés financiers a participé le
secrétaire général y reviendra sans
doute cette évaluation a visé les
dispositifs juridiques le secteur
institutionnel et le secteur privé
schématiquement il s'agissait d'
expertiser toutes les entités de la
chaîne financière les organismes
financiers banques assurances mutuelles
banque de france les intermédiaires
immobilier
les responsables de casino et de société
organisant des jeux de hasard
les experts comptables les commissaires
aux comptes
les notaires huissiers de justice
administrateurs et mandataires
judiciaires les avocats les commissaires
priseurs judiciaires et sociétés de
ventes volontaires de meubles aux
enchères publiques
rassurez-vous tout ça n'est pas du
domaine de la mmf mélo rapport
d'évaluation auquel nous avons participé
a été discuté lors de la réunion
plénière en février 2011
je crois qu'on peut s'enorgueillir du
fait que le gafi à placer la france
parmi les trois pays les plus
performants dans le monde en matière de
lutte anti blanchiment
nous pouvons également souligné que le
président du gafi a présenté le
dispositif conséquent un modèle à suivre
et fait très rare au gafi la france ne
devra rendre compte des améliorations
apportées à son système que tous les
deux ans contre un an pour la plupart
des pays voire six ou trois mois le
rapport du gafi a souligné le caractère
adéquat et exhaustive des mesures visant
à empêcher toute utilisation du secteur
financier à des fins de blanchiment de
capitaux ou de financement du terrorisme
grâce à la transposition d'un troisième
directive anti-blanchiment en complétant
et étant dans un dispositif déjà
l'ide les obligations actuelles de
vigilance à l'égard de la clientèle et
de déclaration des opérations suspectes
imposé aux professionnels financiers
élément clé de tout dispositif national
des standards extrêmement exigeant
qu'elles seules trois pays membres du
liège qui avait été estimé conforme
auparavant sont ainsi jugées très
complète est largement conforme aux
recommandations du gafi
le rapport a relevé également la qualité
de la surveillance exercée sur les
établissements financiers par les
autorités de surveillance
ces autorités de supervision pardon que
ce soit l'autorité de contrôle
prudentiel que vous avez sans doute eu
l'occasion de voir monsieur le président
où l'autorité des marchés financiers
cette surveillance est jugé efficace et
dissuasive contenu de l'action
préventive des contrôles et des
sanctions prononcées par ces autorités
en matière de lutte contre le
blanchiment financement financement du
terrorisme
concrètement la mf sensibilise les
professionnels alors quel professionnel
les sociétés de gestion de portefeuille
les dépositaires les dépositaires
centraux qui sont qui ment cherhal des
banquiers qui exerce ses fonctions
banques et les conseils en
investissement c'est le conseiller yves
ans et ce qui est plus difficile à
surveiller parce que c'est ce qui est
plus nombreux c'est là où des
organisations professionnelles sont les
plus faibles pour être clair à leurs
obligations d'évaluer les risques
encourus avant l'entrée en relation
d'affaires
c'est à dire identifiés et vérifier le
le client et ses opérations ou avant la
réalisation de l'opération et ensuite
durant la relation d'affaires par
l'exercice d'une vigilance constante
leurs obligations devant être renforcée
lorsqu'ils ont affaire à des clients
sans présence physique à des produits
qui favorise l'anonymat et à des
opérations avec des organismes avec des
pays pardon non coopératif de même nous
insistons sur leurs obligations
particulières lorsqu'ils rencontrent des
personnes exposées politiquement et qui
travaillent sur des opérations complexes
d'un montant inhabituellement élevé sans
justification économique apparente ou
sans objet licite apparent alors pour
résumer les obligations à remplir de la
part des professionnels
sont un devoir de vigilance vigilance
constante à l'égard de leurs clients des
bénéficiaires effectifs avec une
identification et vérification de
l'identité des clients et des
bénéficiaires effectifs recueil de toute
information pertinente sur le client je
les dis notamment sur l'objet la nature
de la relation d'affaires
et puis deuxièmement un examen de la
cohérence des opérations effectuées avec
douleur une reconnaissance actualisée
des clients une déclaration à tracfin un
de toute l'opération portant sur des
sommes dont ils savent soupçonne
notamment qu'elle provienne d'une fraude
fiscale s'il ya intervention de
sociétés-écrans opacité ou
sophistication d'opérations financières
non justifiées on regarde les pratiques
habituelles et enfin une mise en place
au sein des professionnels de systèmes
d'évaluation de classification et de
gestion des risques de blanchiment de
capitaux d'une organisation de procédure
interne permettant de satisfaire aux
obligations de vigilance ne contrôle que
j'ai indiqué alors le rôle de l'autorité
des marchés financiers et de contrôler
le respect de ses obligations ainsi que
le cas échéant son pouvoir de sanction à
l'encontre des professionnels les
sanctions en ce domaine encourues sont
les mêmes que pour les autres
manquements et suivent les mêmes
procédures
c'est à dire qu'elles sont établies à la
suite de griefs qui sont dressés par le
collège de l'autorité des marchés
financiers à la suite d' enquêtes qui
sont proposés et conduite par les
services de la m est sous l'autorité du
secrétaire général est transmise ensuite
à une commission des sanctions
commission des sanctions qui est
aujourd'hui présidée par une magistrate
de l'ordre judiciaire qui est madame
claude nocquet et à laquelle ni le
secrétaire général ni moi-même ne sommes
partis donc les sanctions encourues sont
les mêmes que pour les autres
manquements à l'encontre de
professionnels assujettis à faire
avertissements blâmes interdiction à
titre temporaire ou définitive de
l'exercice de tout ou partie des
services fournis sanction pécuniaire
d'un montant de 100 millions d'euros ou
du décuple des profits réalisés
et à l'encontre des personnes physiques
placé sous l'autorité ou agissant pour
le compte de ces professionnels
avertissements blâmes interdiction à
titre temporaire ou définitive de
l'exercice de tout ou partie des
activités sanction pécuniaire d'un
montant de 300 mille euros ou du
quintuple des profits réalisés vous dire
ce serait bien évidemment tous ces
éléments lorsque john l'accomplissement
de ses missions la mf découvre des faits
susceptibles d'être liés au blanchiment
de capitaux comme je les dis elle doit
en informer tactiquement qui la tient
informés des suites réservées à cette
information et nous coopérons
étroitement avec traque fin et nous
avons élaboré et ce dernier des lignes
directrices pour compléter la
réglementation actuelle par un volet
pédagogique à destination des
professionnels relevant de notre
compétence
en effet en instaurant la proche par les
risques en renforçant l'obligation de
déclaration de soupçon a très faim la
transposition a profondément je peux sur
sa transposition de la directive a
profondément modifié les obligations
professionnelles des sociétés de gestion
conseiller financier et en
investissement dépositaire bancaire est
également ceux qui sont chargés des
mécanismes de règlement livraison
d'instruments financiers qui sont aussi
soumis à ce contrôle de la main moi je
voudrais indiquer c'est que ses
relations avec traque fin ont quand même
sous le contrôle du secrétaire général
ses débuts ce président yvon collin jeu
le lait
relation avec très faim ont été
renforcées ces dernières années
si nous étions vus il y a quatre en
trois ou quatre ans je ne vous aurais
pas tenus ces propos
il ya eu un renforcement ça je tiens à
indiquer au parlement des relations
entre tac fin la direction des enquêtes
la direction des contrôles nous avons
une personne qui suit maintenant
davantage ses opérations et il y a eu
des rencontres entre le secrétaire
général de l'aeem eve thierry francq et
le directeur de traitement jean-baptiste
carpentier pour renforcer cette
coopération
alors en ce qui concerne la coopération
internationale et les centres offshore
la coopération internationale je les dis
de la mf s'exerce dans le cadre de ses
enquêtes et de la surveillance des
marchés de l'échangé d'informations sur
les intermédiaires financiers
la liste des états et territoires
considérés comme non coopératifs comme
vous le savez au plan le des changes
d'informations fiscales outils de
l'année 2012 composé du botswana de
brunet du guatemala des îles marshall de
montserrat de nauru denis lui et et des
philippines
à ce jour m f n'a pas eu besoin de
solliciter ses homologues situés dans
ces états elle a en revanche constaté la
réalisation de gros progrès depuis
quelques années dans l'efficacité de la
coopération internationale en matière
boursière et s'estime globalement
satisfaite des réponses apportées à ces
demandes d'informations réelles des pays
avec les horaires et lesquels les
relations sont plus ou moins faciles 1
sera à votre disposition pour vous le
dire mais enfin il m'a même des progrès
qui ont été réalisés et que la suisse
avec israël qui n'est pas toujours
évident l'autorité des marchés
financiers par ailleurs très active dans
les travaux menés au sein de l'oicv pour
favoriser la coopération internationale
nous sommes membres du groupe de travail
portant sur les enquêtes la coopération
internationale les échanges
d'informations entre régulateurs qui
cherche à améliorer la coopération avec
ceux qui sont considérés comme peu
coopératif qu'il soit membre ou non de
l'organisation internationale de
surveillance des marchés l'oicv après
les avoir identifiées à partir de cas
concrets
resté infructueux un dialogue
confidentiel est engagée afin de
comprendre les difficultés trouver des
solutions les obstacles sont
généralement liés aux lois sur le secret
bancaire comme vous pouvez le savoir et
au fait que certaines réglementation
exige la violation préalable d'une loi
locale pour coopérer et ce groupe de
l'autorité internationale de
surveillance des marchés financiers
cherchent également à anticiper
l'apparition de nouveaux centres non
coopératifs utilisé pour faire des
opérations boursières illicites
le nouveau secrétaire général de cette
organisation l'oicv david wright qui est
un britannique mais qui a passé beaucoup
de temps la commission européenne et
particulièrement sensibilisés à ces
sujets c'est quelqu'un joue cia qui
s'expriment remarquablement bien en
français et que vous pourriez dans le
cadre de vos travaux avoir intérêt à
rencontrer parce que d'une part de parce
qu'il a fait à bruxelles et d'autre part
dans ses fonctions dans l'organisation
internationale surveillance des marchés
financiers
c'est quelqu'un qui a une compétence
très grande en ce domaine et qui est
parfaitement clair sur ces sujets donc
cette organisation internationale
participe aussi activement group qui
étudie les candidatures à la signature
de l'accord multilatéral des changes
d'informations sur ces sujets c'est
devenu un standard international qui a
été élaboré par le cv pour faciliter les
échanges d'informations entre ses
signataires dans le cadre d'une enquête
menée sur les suspicions d'infraction
boursière donc chaque candidat membre de
cette organisation internationale doit
pouvoir démontrer doit démontrer aux
membres de ce groupe que son système
juridique lui permet de réunir les
informations demandées de les transmet
sans restriction à leurs homologues afin
d'être utilisé dans les cas prévus à
l'accord et aucun pays sous le contrôle
de thierry ne peut plus aujourd'hui être
admis comme membre de l'oicv s'il ne
peut montrer sa capacité à signer ce
qu'on appelle en mauvais français ce
memorandum of understanding sérieux
ce projet d'accord
donc vous le constatez ce sujet de
l'évasion des capitaux englobe le
fonctionnement des marchés tous les
acteurs de la chaîne financière
je suis aussi lucide c'est à dire que on
croit à chaque fois avoir réalisé de
grands progrès mais c'est comme l'hydre
à kiel on coupe la tête à chaque fois
cela repousse de manière différente tant
les différentes ramifications est
intacte hull sont importants donc
surtout lorsque nous nos assujettis je
ne parle pas des institutions
financières qui ont l'habitude de cette
coopération notamment avec tracts faim
et qui coopère bien en direct la licra
de faim mais nous nous avons des
sociétés de gestion de grandes
dimensions nous avons des sociétés de
gestion de très petite dimension et
comme je les dis nous avons des milliers
de 2,2 de conseil en investissant
financier qui nous est très difficile de
2,2 de surveiller pour vous donner un
exemple il ya plusieurs milliers de de
concilier d'investissements financiers
en france on a réalisé avec les moyens
qui sont ceux de l'autorité des marchés
financiers voilà enfin on a fait une
dizaine de contrôles bien choisie par le
secrétaire général d'ailleurs qui permet
de ceux des dab a suivi les cas les plus
délicats
enfin vous voyez la proportion entre le
champ de la profession je le redis au
parlement et le le le nom de contrôle
qui peuvent être faites et les orgues
l'organisation professionnelle qui doit
contrôler ses conseils en
investissements financiers parce que je
le redis ici tant que cette profession
ne sera pas suffisamment cadrée on
connaîtra toujours dans ce domaine que
ce soit dans le domaine des délits
boursiers et ce qui peut recueillir ce
qui peut être recouvert en termes de
lutte contre le blanchiment
beaucoup de difficultés voilà ce que je
souhaitais vous dire avant que le
secrétaire général beaucoup plus avant
que moi puisse répondre aux questions
relatives aux enquêtes diligence et
coopération avec les différents états
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
merci monsieur président donc
je vais passer la parole au rapporteur
et monsieur le secrétaire général de
vouziers quelque chose à compléter
monsieur le secrétaire général mais je
pense que j'ai cru comprendre que
j'étais dans la réponse aux questions
que cela se ferait alors monsieur le
rapporteur des questions bien merci
monsieur le président première question
assez générales sur votre votre
organisation d'abord j'aimerais
connaître les moyens dont vous disposez
dans votre autorité
et puis bon vous l'avez évoqué très
brièvement mais l'organisation de votre
de vos services et ensuite les
procédures comment fonctionnez-vous est
ce que vous exercez un contrôle au fil
de l'eau de manière systématique ou
c'est sur la base d'un soupçon d'un
signalement à téhéran voilà ce que
pourrait nous expliquer dans un premier
temps votre organisation générale s'il
vous plaît oui la mmf compte 440
collaborateurs aujourd'hui
enfin c'est à lui ni tout à fait à
l'unité près ça change tous les jours
mais environ 440 pour surveiller les
transactions financières à la bourse de
paris
pour vous donner une idée aujourd'hui on
les ordres passés la bourse de paris en
une année le l'échelle c'est le milliard
aujourd'hui le milliard de transactions
pour surveiller environ 700 sociétés
cotées ou qui font appel à l'épargné
publique pour surveiller environ 7 600
sociétés de gestion 700 autres
prestataires de services
d'investissement et environ 6000
conseillers en investissements
financiers
le lej ajoute que au delà des
transactions boursières à la bourse de
paris est en cours l'extension du champ
de la surveillance de la mf à tous types
de produits
dérivés y compris les dérivés sur
matières premières et paris est un
centre où il y à quelques activités
notamment dans le domaine agricole le
est également nous sommes depuis peu le
surveillant nous sommes compétents en
masse sur le marché des quotas de co2
donc voilà l'univers que nous devons
surveiller contrôler le lait notre
dispositif est organisée de la manière
suivante nous avons d'une part des
équipes qui assure une surveillance
alors surveillance des transactions se
sont d une équipe dédiée et chaque jour
nous faisons que nous passons des tests
statistiques sur l'ensemble des
transactions que nous recevons pour
détecter des mouvements anormaux et
ensuite nous les analysons pour donner
une idée il ya environ 300 alerte qui
nous remontent chaque jour évidemment
beaucoup ont une explication facile et
celles qui sont plus énigmatique nous
menons une analyse de sekkaki ensuite
peuvent déboucher sur une décision de ma
part déboucher sur une enquête le nous
avons aussi développé une surveillance
accrue des intermédiaires financiers
nous avions déjà depuis longtemps une
surveillance assez importante et
rapprocher des sociétés de gestion de
portefeuille
nous avons décidé d'accentuer aussi la
surveillance des agissements des
différents intermédiaires de marché donc
ici c'est la veille en amont pour
détecter
des problèmes et nous avons deux autres
équipes qui elles sont les équipes de
contrôleurs et d'enquêteurs qui au vu
donc de cette surveillance ou de
dénonciations de l'extérieur aussi des
cas qui nous proviennent de cette
manière nous déclare lorsque lorsqu il
nous semble que nous pouvons subodorer
soupçonné soit un délit un manquement
boursiers manquement d'initié
manipulation de cours ou fausses
informations ou un manquement aux
obligations professionnelles des
professionnelles et professionnels
réglementé nous déclenchons un contrôle
pour pour les les contrôles sont sont
réservés aux manquements aux obligations
professionnelles ou une enquête qui
elles sont ciblées sur les manquements
boursiers c'est dans le cadre de ces
enquêtes notamment que nous pouvons si
j'ose dire tomber sur une situation qui
nous font alors soit des mouvements
anormaux que nous ne pouvons pas relié à
des manquements boursiers et à ce moment
là nous indiquons simplement nous
transmettons un tract fin ce que nous
savons de ces mouvements anormaux
à eux de voir si ça peut relever d'une
d'une logique de blanchiment quel que
soit le délit sous jacent met donc y
compris la fraude fiscale si nous
tombons sur un cas où il nous paraît ou
en en étant fasse clairement d'un délit
y compris un délit fiscal
à ce moment là nous transmettons la
sphère au parquet mais donc nous ne
recherchons pas en cas d enquête délit
fiscal
mais nous nous comme indiqué le
président il nous arrive bien entendu 2
de tomber sur des cas de ce type comme
les deux exemples qui ont été soulignés
par le président le et dans le cadre des
contrôles ici alors nous pouvons tomber
aussi sur un cas de fraude fiscale mais
ce qui arrive le plus souvent c'est
plutôt des déficiences en matière
d'organisation dans la lutte contre le
blanchiment des professionnels et en
fonction du degré de gravité de ces
insuffisances
nous demandons nous exigeons une mise au
carré du professionnel où nous proposons
collège de notifier des griefs contre x
pour les cas les plus graves en vue
d'une éventuelle sanction
pour donner un ordre
d'idées nous avons une trentaine de
contrôleurs une quarantaine d'enquêteurs
et pour effectuer la surveillance à la
fois je parle pas des sociétés cotées
puisque nous soyons aussi des sociétés
cotées mais la surveillance des
professionnels financiers et des
transactions financières
en réalité les moyens les plus
importants sont les moyens informatiques
william sommes dans une jeune enfin dans
une dans un océan de données de
transaction donc l'homme n'y suffit pas
mais il faut aussi de l'intelligence
pour pour cela il nous avons une
trentaine de collaborateurs qui sont
dédiés à la surveillance toutefois des
transactions et des professionnels
vraiment encore merci pour cette
présentation vous savez les citer le
chiffre d'un milliard de transactions
jours où c'était alors son palais de
transactions ce sont les ordres passés
en beau fils qui ne donne pas toujours
lieu à des transactions mais nous
auscultent ont aussi pas seulement les
transactions mais aussi les ordres
notamment pour détecter des cas de
manipulation est aujourd'hui jeu on est
à plusieurs milliards d'ordres se ce
sont des statistiques un peu mou vente
mais c'est l'ordre de grandeur par an
vous avez donc citer 300 cas d' alerte
donc délit d'initié manipulation cours
fausses informations c'est l'essentiel
ça c'est par jour par jour des alertes
qui viennent des tests statistiques
encore une fois vous l'été statistiques
bon ont leurs limites et donc sur les
300 cas il est bien évident qu'il y a la
majorité des cas s'explique très
simplement par ailleurs et donc ne donne
pas lieu à un analyse poussée donc pour
pour donner un ordre de grandeur pour
les enquêtes donc les abus de marché les
manquements boursiers l'analyse poussée
des alertes et parfois parfois des des
soupçons qui sont dénoncés par soit des
professionnels soi même
l heure parfois des particuliers donnent
lieu à l'ouverture d'environ une une
entre 40 et 50 enquêtes par an nous
menons aussi des enquêtes à la demande
de nos homologues étrangers lorsqu'une
partie de ce qui les intéresse c'est
assez en france où est liée aux
agissements de personnes françaises est
ce qui vous est arrivé dans ces alertes
de repérer des faits de fraude fiscale
alors au haut niveau d alerte 6 mais
nous voyons des mouvements
il est
il est généralement pas possible de
déterminer immédiatement qu'il s'agit
d'une fraude fiscale on détermine assez
facilement un certain nombre
d'opérations qui sont facilement
expliquées par ce qu'on peut appeler
l'optimisation fiscale et qui est légal
ça il ya quelques cas classique selon
salé selon par exemple typiquement le
versement du dividende ou du coupon
d'une obligation en fonction de la
situation fiscale des investisseurs ils
peuvent avoir intérêt à ne pas recevoir
le dividende est donc faire un aller
retour est plutôt avoir une plus value
loup plutôt une win une plus value donc
on il ya des opérations de ce type qui
s'explique très bien par des
considérations fiscales et très
immédiatement sans qu'elle soit
dénonçables pour
pour arriver à la conclusion qu'il y à 1
manifestement ou de façon quasi certaine
un délit fiscal qui donne lieu donc
transmission au parquet généralement
c'est suite à c'est au cours d'une
enquête parce qu'il faut aller plus loin
que le simple examen d'une transaction
et s'il nous arrive dans ses analyses
liées aux alertes de pensée qui n'est
pas possible il est très improbable que
ce soit liée à un manquement boursiers
et donc à ce moment là nous n'allons pas
ouvrir une enquête puisque c'est notre
but
mais en revanche considéré que
l'opération paraît bizarre et à ce
moment là nous nous transmettons cette
opération au attractif a donc au terme
de ces différents processus il vous est
arrivé de vous rirez face à des délits
reconnue établie
combien de transmission s'adonner dire
combien de transmission au parquet dans
l'ensemble des affaires vous avez est
traitée et pour quelle nature de fait
précisément sous couvert d'anonymat bien
sûr mais la nature des faits
m'intéresserait de transporter les
professionnels de près les sens c'est
évidemment assez aléatoire puisque
encore une fois c'est pas ce que nous
recherchons donc c'est dire à l'occasion
de nos enquêtes donc ces quelques unités
par an le
alors on a on a cité quelques quelques
cas de figure ci est fictif opération
dissimulation de de bénéfices des
sociétés
nous nous soyons clairs nous détectons
surtout des des fraudes fiscales liées
aux personnes morales puisque pour les
personnes physiques
le pour les personnes morales vous avez
le sens économique de l'opération qui
vous guide pour les personnes physiques
c'est beaucoup plus difficile
tout mouvement financier d'une manière
ou d'une autre peut s'expliquer en
personne physique peut trouver des
explications raisonnable donc ça
concentrer beaucoup sur les personnes
morales toutes les personnes physiques
bien entendu il peut nous arriver et
dans une enquête de 2,2
de voir le compte un conte très content
important dans un pays des pays qui
peuvent laisser penser
une partie de ces sommes sont sont le
fruit de fraude fiscale mais sens mais
ça ne peut-être qu'un vague soupçons et
et là il est bien évident que rien
apporté là où nous ne vous nous ne nous
pouvons aller plus loin que je gardais
dans le coin de la tête que peut-être il
était dû un jour une fraude fiscale qui
explique ces la nature ses comptes mais
encore une fois il nous faut quand même
des éléments sérieux sérieux de
d'anormalité pour envoyer des éléments
traque fin et il faut une non pas
certitude puisque nous ne sommes pas
juge pénal mais une femme très forte un
très forts soupçons une forte
présomption pour envoyer un dossier au
parquet ah ça mène à la question
suivante dans le vôtre travail de suivi
des régulations de contrôle de
l'activité bancaire on sait que de
nombreuses banques françaises ont des
entités dans les paradis fiscaux et les
aides dont j'imagine confrontés à cette
réalité aujourd'hui aussi dans le cadre
de votre enquête
comment comment vous comportez vous par
rapport à sa situation quand il existe
des structures opaques dans un organisme
bancaire mondial implanté dans des
paradis fiscaux offshore est ce que vous
suivez un peu plus particulièrement les
ordres provenant de ces territoires la
quelle est votre attitude quelle est
votre démarche votre stratégie par
rapport à cette difficulté à laquelle
vous devez j'imagine être confrontés
alors il ya 22.6 premiers éléments nous
ne contrôlons pas
les banques de façon générale c'est
l'autorité contrôlerez dans ce rude en
ciel qui produit qui contrôle les
banques nous nous nous contrôlons nous
surveillons certaines activités des
banques
lorsqu'ils sont prestataires de services
d'investissement
le donc pour les dispositifs anti
blanchiment l'organisation des
dispositifs anti blanchiment à
l'intérieur des groupes bancaires
c'est l'autorité de contrôle prudentiel
donc qui est eux qui est en charge le le
alors deuxième point
quelles sont les informations que nous
recevons automatiquement les
transactions donc sujets qui s'est
encore une fois de des transactions
boursières classique ou aux marchés
dérivés
nous recevons toutes les transactions
menées par une quelconque à un
quelconque intermédiaire financier en
europe sur pour pour notre domaine de
compétence donc typiquement une valeur
cotée à la bourse de paris
nous recevons ces transactions
automatiquement chaque jour donc de
l'ensemble de l'europe le mais ce que
nous recevons nous n'avons pas
l'identité du bénéficiaire de
l'opération nous avons l'identité de
l'intermédiaire financier et donc si
nous souhaitons lorsque nous jugeons
qu'il faut analyser plus avant la
transaction si nous souhaitons
l'analyser il faut alors demander à
l'intermédiaire financier de nous donner
le nom de 2
la personne qui est derrière la
transaction et à ce moment là c'est là
que nous pouvons arriver dans un centre
offshore
typiquement un intermédiaire sera
généralement européens sera européen
mais le le bénéficiaire et monique de
l'opération peut être installés en
europe en dehors de l'europe et dans un
centre offshore à ce moment là le pour
aller plus loin dans les investigations
nous demandons les informations à notre
autorité soeur dans le pays en question
y compris le sens les centres offshore
et de ce point de vue là il faut bien
avouer que la plupart des centres
offshore
avec qui à qui nous avons eu à faire ces
dernières années qu'au père
effectivement alors je crois qu'il faut
dire les choses clairement s'il coopère
effectivement c'est parce qu'ils savent
que nous ne recherchons pas de délits
fiscaux
mais des délits boursiers voilà et que
la plupart des centres offshore ont bien
compris que ne pas coopérer pour les
délits boursiers c'est ce n'est pas bon
pour leur image le centre financier
il ya peut-être des raisonnements un peu
différent matière fiscale sur l' enquête
vous avez cité deux enquêtes notamment
une concernant les sociétés qui avait un
siège social au luxembourg
quelle était l'attitude du luxembourg ce
qu'ils ont été très coopératifs sur le
domaine sur le sujet il n'y a eu aucune
difficulté effectivement question
suivante c est ce que votre rôle votre
travail évoluer et si oui dans quelle
mesure et dans quelles proportions
depuis les derniers g20 notamment celui
où on avait un peu inscrit à l'ordre du
jour la lutte contre les paradis fiscaux
et l'évasion en 2009 est ce que votre
rôle s'en est trouvé renforcé est
modifié et si oui de quelle manière le
sur le
là sur la fraude fiscale le nom en tant
que telle non il est en revanche il est
tout à fait clair qu' il y à une
pression accrue sur les pays qui reste
non coopératifs ou peu coopératif
vis-à-vis de nous le
e
donc ça exerce une pression supérieure
on voit bien qu'un certain nombre de
pays cherche à montrer que joue le jeu
on a aussi enfin il faut il faut je
pense qu'il faut le dire on a aussi des
grands pays émergents
beaucoup coopèrent très bien certains
sont moins à l'aise pour coopérer et ont
une pression s'exerce plus fortement sur
le jeu ne dis pas qu'ils ne sont pas
coopératifs mais je pense qu'il y a il y
a une habitude à a créé je vais prendre
un exemple la chine
jusqu'à une période récente nous n'avons
n'avions pas coopéré avec les chiffres
nous n'avions pas de cas réellement cela
c'était le cas pour l'ensemble des
occidentaux le monde change très vite
aujourd'hui nous commençons à avoir
besoin de l'aide de la chine dans
certaines de nos enquêtes on sent bien
qu'ils ne sont pas complètement à l'aise
mais je jeu dans le cadre du g20 je ne
doute pas que si la coopération est un
peu long aujourd'hui qu'elle se
elle s'améliore dans les dents les
l'avenir non les trimestres à venir
le trimestre à venir voilà madame ou
monsieur le président je vous remercie
beaucoup pour la clarté de votre propos
on l'a bien compris la fraude fiscale
n'est pas votre coeur de métier je
dirais que c'est une activité annexe
connexes et lorsque vous avez des doutes
ou des interrogations
vous transmettez les dossiers au parquet
je me posais la question de savoir c'est
ma première question si ensuite vous
faites un travail et un petit peu de
réflexion ou statistiques sur le nombre
de cas que vous avez transmis au parquet
d'une part et d'autre part ce que ces
cas transmis au parquet en donner c'est
à dire si le suivi et de 50% est ce
qu'un tiers des cas vous avez signalé
ont été suivis de poursuites pénales ou
pas donc ça c'est ma première question
le suivi des cas transmis au parquet
évidemment on comprend le rôle crucial
de la politique du parquet en la matière
deuxième question vous nous avait bien
signalé la zone de flou avec un certain
nombre de professions peu réglementé des
entreprises un petit peu voilà diverses
en conseil moi j'avais plutôt envie de
vous poser la question en amont du rôle
des conseils d'administration nos
grandes entreprises françaises vous
savez comme moi que l'antre soyez très
pratique et qu'un grand nombre
d'administrateurs croule sous le travail
les dossiers et on m'a expliqué pour
arrêter furtivement dans un grand
conseil d'administration que le principe
de confiance était dominant et qu'a
priori on n'est plus chez pas un dossier
de façon exhaustive avant d'une session
est qu en fait seuls quelques membres du
conseil d'administration dans une
répartition des rôles vais à l'avance
planchait sur ces questions là et donc
je m'interrogeais sur votre vision du
rôle français des conseils
d'administration notamment par rapport à
ce qui peut se pratiquer en allemagne où
la de tout le monde sait que le rôle des
administrateurs correspond à une autre
culture à une autre formation il ya du
training avant tout les conseils
d'administration et donc là je dirais il
ya une culture différente de
l'administrateur est-ce que vous avez
une vision de cela et troisième et
dernière question évidemment ça c'est
plus au coeur de votre métier
le rôle de l'information le
la communication d'informations les
fuites et la juste vous poser la
question suivante on a en france une
profession journalistique très
courageuse et qui fait très très bien
son métier
pour autant on a des groupes de presse
ceux qui ont des intérêts extrêmement
liés à des grands groupes industriels à
des grands groupes bancaires et donc
dans ce domaine là qu'elle est un petit
peu la marge de manoeuvre dont vous
bénéficiez sachant que l'information
c'est de l'argent et que là on travaille
sur des choses extrêmement sensible avec
des rumeurs des fausses rumeurs des
contres informations et derrière le
marché des consultants je dirais qu'il a
aussi aide les entreprises lorsqu'elles
sont en difficulté mais qui vous le
savez comme moi peuvent aussi mettre en
difficulté des entreprises rivales ou
concurrentes en faisant des phosphites
des défauts informations des rumeurs etc
je vous remercie très bien même la
vice-présidente alors avec eux mêmes de
thierry nous allons vous répondre on n'a
pas fait de 2,2 de statistiques haddock
sur les dossiers relative relatifs à des
opérations de lutte contre le
blanchiment de fiances peinture en
risque de fraude fiscale adressé au
parquet en revanche nous tenons des
statistiques sur tout dossier à la suite
d' enquête de contrôle où dalet que nous
transmettons au parquet et nous avons
les quelques jours fait met à jour ses
statistiques en ce qui concerne les
enquêtes vu quelles étaient les dossiers
qui restaient sans suite vu les dossiers
dans quel temps il était traité par
rapport à aux délais de traitement de
l'autorité des marchés financiers
voilà d'une manière générale ce que je
puis vous dire la vice présidente c'est
que la comparaison n'est pas au
déshonneur au désavantage de l'autorité
des marchés financiers que ce soit en
terme de sanction ou que ce soit en
termes de délais de traitement
deuxièmement en ce qui concerne les
conseils d'administration alors là on
est pour vous dire vous ai cité le
modèle allemand l'existant enfin chacun
sait que je suis attaché ou franco
allemand y aussi un modèle britannique
qui en ce domaine là existent et qui
n'est pas mauvais non plus qui composent
aussi c'est là dessus les mêmes français
qu'il s'est amélioré cet avenir est
d'une part en terme de formation parce
que vous avez par exemple un institut
comme la formation des administrateurs
je sais pas si vous avez auditionné
daniel lebègue il ya des progrès
importants qui ont été faits en matière
de formation des administrateurs
d'information je crois véritablement là
aussi ces récents mais qu'il y a des
améliorations qui ont été qui ont été
faites
deuxièmement il faut distinguer et nous
l'avons fait dans le cadre de l'autorité
des marchés financiers puisque nous
avons conduit un groupe de travail sur
tout ce qui était la répartition des
tâches entre les conseils des comités
d'audit et il est assez légitime il se
trouve que avec thierry francq pour
avoir été à la direction du trésor
nous avons été nous mêmes
administrateurs thiery plus que moi s'il
est resté plus longtemps de deux
sociétés à participation publique et les
soldes par lorsque nous connaissons dans
la pratique en tant qu'administrateur
les dossiers vous les examiner et dépend
de chacun des administrateurs que de ça
mais si lisez aussi il n'y a pas de
règle enfin moi j'en passe sous contrôle
de thierry qui interdisent un
administrateur de poser des questions
d'avoir accès à un dossier et il serait
anormal et il faudrait à ce moment là le
dire en termes de gouvernance à
l'autorité des marchés financiers qui à
part en tant qu elle de pouvoir
réglementaire médias droit de voir
comment certains codes de conduite c'est
au législateur de répondre de savoir
s'il faut aller plus loin en ce domaine
mais de voir si c'est pratique de de
bonne gouvernance ont respecté ou pas
par rapport à ce que les codes dits fait
mais nef dix mois pour ma part vous avez
le comité d'audit qui a des fonctions
particulières vous avez les comités de
nomination et de rémunération ou
aujourd'hui ce qui n'était pas le cas
toujours lorsqu'elle est thierry francq
nous étions la direction du trésor
les représentants de l'état par exemple
sont membres aujourd'hui ce qui n'était
pas ce qui n'a pas toujours été le cas
là vous avez raison et je crois qu'il
appartient plus d'administrateurs de
regarder les dossiers - tout cas thierry
répondra pour sa part j'ai pas vu ou pas
eu connaissance à la mf ne plane
d'administrateur nous faisons ne
pourront pas avoir accès à tel ou tel
dossier où il ya une répartition qui est
tel ou tel après c'est là pour eu pour
l'autorité des marchés financiers la
responsabilité de l'administrateur reste
individuelle elle est collective dans
son dans son dans son conseil s'il n'a
pas fait son travail c'est une
responsabilité
troisièmement sur la profession
journalistique nous ce que nous
souhaitons c'est nous contrôlons d'une
part et la qualité de l'information
l'objectivité de l'information
l'exhaustivité de l'information à
travers les documents qui sont donnés
par la société et que ce soir nous vous
comprendrez que sur ce bois je sois
prudent mais peut-être le secrétaire
général complétera mais lorsque nous
sommes en présence de rumeurs de 2,2 de
2,2 de fausses rumeurs quel que soit le
respect que nous devons tous à
l'indépendance journalistique mais
lorsque nous apercevons qu'il ya des
tentatives ou de manipulation ou de
rumeurs dans la presse
nous faisons nos enquêtes et contrôles
incluant ces rumeurs est auditionné les
représentants de la presse
quel qu'il soit sur les rumeurs et la
manière dont ces rumeurs sont apparues
dans la presse pas si le secret d'hergé
rassure ce point
moi souhaitent oui pour pour pour les
jeunes agissent faut il faut distinguer
un cas particulier qui sont les
journalistes qui soit amené à faire des
recommandations
voilà d'investissement là il y à des
dispositions pour qu'ils sont assez
particulière parce que bien entendu
n'est pas question de remettre en cause
secret des sources etc etc mais ils
doivent appliquer des règles de
déontologie particulière parce qu'il est
bien mais il nous est arrivé et déjà
d'enquêter sur sur des journalistes qui
avaient fait des recommandations et on
s'est posé la question de savoir si il y
avait un intérêt
personnel à faire ses recommandations à
ma connaissance aucun jeu ma mémoire
remonte peut-être pas assez loin mais
nous avons plusieurs fois mené d enquête
là-dessus nous n'avons à ce jour jamais
détecté deux acteurs d'opération alors
si j'y pensais pas tout de suite
excusez moi mais c'est une sanction
public donc je peux l'indiqué il ya un
cas c'est nicolas miguet qui se trouve
être journaliste n'est oublié cet aspect
qui a été condamnée récemment parlé mef
pour cela les je précise qu'il y a des
recours en cour mais le donc le voilà
nous nous pouvons nous pouvons nous
avons quand même des moyens d'action
alors au delà de ça le relais de rumeurs
c'est un cas beaucoup plus difficiles à
traiter
il est tout à fait clair que le secret
des sources s'applique donc nous n'avons
pas le pouvoir même de demander un
journaliste la source de la rumeur qui
la reliait voilà est bon nous nous
cherchons quand même à enquêter sans
mais il est tout à fait clair que c'est
extrêmement difficile
c'est d'autant plus difficile quand le
journaliste est en plus à l'étranger
arrivé il ya une enquête en cours sur
une rumeur c'est un câble bien connu oui
nous nous nous nous essayons nous et si
nous nous nous enquêtons aussi sur
internet
ce qui n'est pas non plus très facile
mais on a quand même d'aider des moyens
il faut quand même souligner que la
plupart des rumeurs que
l'on entend bon il peut y avoir des le
enfin la plupart des rumeurs qui nous
semble avoir donné lieu possiblement à
des opérations financières ou avoir des
rumeurs qui n'ont pas eu d'impact parce
qu'elle n'était pas crédible donc ça ne
ça ne ça ne nous préoccupe pas trop
en revanche des rumeurs qui ont eu un
impact soyons clairs dans la plupart des
cas nous sommes amenés à investiguer
dans des salles de marché et donc il ya
peut-être eu le truchement un moment
donné d'un journalisme et c'est quand
même souvent là que ça se passe
et là aussi ça n'est pas facile de
d'enquêté mais nous ne désespérons pas
mais soyons clairs les rumeurs c'est un
des sujets les plus difficiles à
appréhender dans le cas d'une enquête
c'est pour tous les la terre d'ailleurs
qu'ils soient français allemand je pense
que ça vaut pas seulement pour la
matière boursière
la parole est un monsieur vaugrenard
merci monsieur le président en vous
entendant monsieur le président la
mission sur l'intérêt général je suis
bien compris que la coopération
internationale semblait être plus
importante lorsqu'il s'agit de délits
boursiers que lorsqu'il s'agit de délits
de fraude fiscale sont utiles une
constatation
va partager vous avez évoqué de pearl
organisations internationales de
surveillance des marchés financiers
je veux savoir si au niveau du
territoire européen pas seulement
l'union européenne du territoire
européen
si cette coopération est est importante
et plus importante
et est ce que ce fait y compris en
direction des états qui aujourd'hui sont
jugés comme coopératif alors qu'il reste
quand même des paradis fiscaux par
exemple avec le luxembourg avec les îles
anglo-normandes andorre monaco où la
suisse par exemple et vous nous disiez
que lorsqu'il y avait des enquêtes à
votre demande les homologues étrangers
vous savez si tu es le luxembourg
répondait de manière positive aux
demandes d' enquête dès lors qu'il
s'agissait de deux délits boursiers
nous avons constaté dans les différentes
auditions que lorsqu'il s'agit il
s'agissait dans la quête menée par un
juge
c'était beaucoup plus compliqué est-ce
que de manière un peu réciproque vous
avez des demandes de vos homologues
étrangers dans quête de délits boursiers
en france de la part des pays que je
viens de citer
deuxième point la difficulté dans tout
cela que ce soit dans les délits de
fraude fiscale ou dans les délits
boursiers c'est que on a le sentiment
d'avoir toujours un temps de retard
ceux qui souhaitent fraude est un peu
parfois un temps d'avancé sur nous donc
au sein de l'autorité des marchés
financiers est ce qu'il existe une
cellule de recherche d'innovation
notamment par rapport aux progrès
technologiques pour permettre d'avoir
l'ambition d'avoir un temps d'avancé par
rapport à ce qui de toutes manières sont
toujours à la recherche de contourner la
loi ou les moyens que nous mettons en
place et est ce que ceux ci existent ou
si ça n'existe pas si ça existait ce que
c'est suffisant selon vous est ce que
vous avez en quelque sorte les moyens de
votre ambition quoi troisième point on
constate
souvent que l'exemplarité peut être un
bon moyen d'éviter la fraude fiscale est
probablement aussi les délits boursiers
donc lorsque vous constatez des délits
boursiers
quels sont les moyens que vous mettez en
oeuvre pour en faire un minimum de
communication pour que précisément
l'exemplarité soit aussi source
d'efficacité
merci bien c'est très clair je regrette
sur l'aspect fiscal et boursiers je
suppose que vous avez entendu également
les agents de la direction générale des
impôts et de la direction de la
législation fiscale pas ce pour avoir
commencé ma carrière dans ces domaines
je ne voudrais pas laisser croire qu'ils
ne font pas eux aussi le maximum en
matière de coopération pour avoir ces
différentes informations il ya aussi une
commère une coopération administrative
fiscale ce que nous avons dit que ce
cratère géant c'est que c'est pas nous
qui en est qui ont cherché au niveau
européen il ya une coopération qui est
qui est forte on a des coopérations sur
des délits boursiers les les
vous avez cité les pays qui présentait
parfois le plus de difficultés si je
m'en tiens à l'union européenne sous
contrôle de 2,2 de thierry en matière d'
enquête s'il faut que vous sachiez c'est
que c'est également partagé c'est à dire
que aujourd'hui près de la moitié des
enquêtes
la moitié des travaux que nous faisons
sont liés à de la coopération ou
européennes ou internationales
c'est à dire que ça une composante
internationale ça c'est aussi un fait
nouveau avant ça se faisait dans le
cadre national maintenant on reçoit jeu
pendant une quarantaine de cas dans la
quarantaine de cas dans les statistiques
mensuelles que je reçois avec le
secrétaire général on voit que la moitié
ont une origine européenne ou
internationale
donc ça vaut dans l'est dans les deux
sens pour être clair avec vous avec un
certain nombre de pays
on a plus de difficultés à poser les
règles c'est à dire
faire en sorte que nous soyons bien
d'accord sur les règles qui vont limiter
au maximum les délais boursier où les
arbitrages réglementaires ou les
arbitrages fiscaux liés à des
interprétations réglementaires ou sur de
la législation européenne
c'est le cas que nous avons avec le
luxembourg aujourd'hui grâce à l'action
du secrétaire général et en cas de
résolution et c'est plus dans ce dans ce
cadre là que nous avons un problème
c'est sur les règles
qu'est ce que savait qu est ce qu on a
voulu dire exactement sur la
distribution de tel et tel prix